rolling in here with this [ __ ] fake
ass haircut but here's the thing some
people you come with a certain style you
get then people are going to say you're
a certain thing it scared me because it
seemed like it wasn't gonna catch on
dude if you're over there you got my
hair cut but here's the thing bro it's
not a mullet okay it is a display of
your heart it's a display of your
Ambiance bruh when I watched you on uh
on Joe Rogan I was like oh my god dude
this guy is like new haircut new special
do do dumb people ever think that you're
Mexican yeah wow I'm not saying that
that's sexually suggestive yeah yeah bro
do you ever get nervous that when you're
ejaculating a lot of women now will hold
it and sneak off and use it you know or
they'll save it real quick another
person like a heating environment and
then get rid of it later I'm gonna try
to get us tickets to another fight man
and you know what you would do is
probably you would just take my hair and
then and just make yours just like mine
is exactly here's the thing have you
ever done